hello my name is matt
and you're watching my youtube channel
go to tech tutorials
today i want to tell you uh
today i want to talk about the story of
how i became a programmer
and why i got so interested in computers
and technology
and i was thinking about this a bunch
last night and this morning
and i thought i'd just tell it because
i guess it's easier for me to reflect
that way if i can go back and watch what
i said because as i was walking through
it
you know i guess there wasn't really a
clear defining moment when it happened
it was kind of in steps
and things just sort of happened this
way for me and i didn't really
i feel like i didn't really choose this
it pretty much
kind of chose me and
through telling my story maybe it'll
help somebody and also maybe i'll figure
out
more of why because
i don't i don't fully understand it but
i'm just gonna go chronologically
and tell you a little about my life
probably leave out a lot of the personal
details but i'll give you like
an overview of what i was doing at
certain areas of my life
so you can see this background of cows
and stuff
i was born on a farm
and my dad was a dairy farmer
my mom was pretty much a
you know stayed at home took care of the
kids i have an older brother
and i have an older sister so we did
have somewhat of a
complete family unit mother father
brother sister and i was the youngest
kid
so i feel lucky for that in a lot of
ways but
things well we'll get to it i don't want
to
spoil anything but i know a lot of
people out there from
broken homes and didn't have a mom or
didn't have a dad
that kind of thing is actually like
always heartbreaking for me to hear
because even though as you'll kind of
find out my family was a little messed
up
it was still really nice to actually
have a mom and dad so i really
i can't discount how how much it's uh
actually helped me you know be confident
and stuff in my life
all right the story yeah so when i was a
young chap
we were on a farm my dad got up early
milked cows
plowed fields planted corn
uh i think their his main source of
income at that time was
selling dairy to uh the locals and
stores and everything they bottled up
the milkman would come pick it up
this was in the 80s and i was born i
guess on a really
really cold winter and
one of the coldest in a long time it was
like negative 20.
so that was interesting i guess but i
don't have
many memories from being young i think
the only one i actually have was
i guess i have a few of like big
machinery and stuff and i remember a
pond with
big goldfish in it that someone must
have threw in there
uh hold on actually i have i think i
have a picture of this farm
hold on
okay well i think it's buried somewhere
in a box but it's basically
a a farmhouse with a little pond and
some fields it's
nothing super special but here are some
other random pictures
to kind of let you know just a little
just a little bit of where it came from
how i became a mechanical incline and
that sort of thing
but i was really young at this time this
is a picture my dad
kept can you see this i don't know of uh
this this dude over here i don't
remember his name
my dad knew all this stuff but he passed
so i don't remember all these guys names
but this is one of my relatives way back
in the day
before before cars apparently but
yeah at some point they uh
migrated over here we'll say
uh a few more pictures these are kind of
dirty but
especially this one my parents when they
were when they were happy
i like to say um
and my dad's family i don't have many
pictures of my mom's family
but uh where's my dad i think he's over
here
yeah and my two aunts this is hard i
have to do in reverse
and my grandparents so
that's how i grew up that's uh well
that's how i grew up that that doesn't
finalize anything this is uh
the thing from milk marketing that my
dad got my parents got
some kind of award for selling milk i
guess i don't know
but yeah i got these pictures when he
passed it was all the stuff in his house
there's a ton of them
but that's how i grew up basically on a
farm
well i say grew up but we'll get to that
uh this big farm i believe my parents
sold it when i was about
three or four the last memory i have of
the farm is having my uh getting
my feet stuck in mud because we had cows
and stuff of course and
they would make a bunch of mud around
the barn they stayed in and
i got my foot stuck in it i remember my
sister helping pull me out
bond memories fond memories and also i
got stuck on top of silo and
so from from a really early age
i was like out running around seeing all
these big mechanical things
and you know having a brother and sister
i was probably starting to get an idea
of kind of how to mechanically
problem solve a little bit my dad was
always fixing things and stuff like that
so i
was watching do that but all right let's
move on past
those super early years where i lived on
a big farm and
talk about the next phase there were
little phases in between
i think after selling the place my uh
parents or you know my dad stayed with
one of his sisters one of the ones in
that picture
and some other stuff happened that is
more personal and
has more to do with the reason they sold
it and stuff but it doesn't really have
anything to do with
anything other than someone did some
messed up stuff
and things had to change basically so my
family
sold the place and left as far as i best
know
so that story isn't entirely clear to me
it's kind of
it's kind of a family secret sort of
thing so i'm still
trying to unravel it but it
i don't know maybe i'll talk about it
more on my personal channel sometime but
not here on code tech and tutorials
so yeah we bounced around for about a
year or two
staying with other family until we got a
new place
and we settled down and another
farmhouse on the outskirts of a
kind of small city i don't want to name
any names and that's where i ended up
uh growing up from like age five to
adopt adulthood
it's actually really hard for me to like
i don't know just the nostalgia is just
kind of overrunning me talking about
this and i'm like almost tearing up
i didn't think this would happen but uh
you know
all right so a little change of pace so
i grew up in kind of a small town still
on the outskirts of
the city and in general kind of
living the country life you know we had
uh 60 acres
woods fields hills it was
it was a really nice family home for a
small family
and you know thinking about it now i
i guess at the time i was growing up i i
really had no idea how
i guess influential and kind of precious
these
years were but thinking about it now
they were
they were really something quite special
and
something i'll never forget and
anyway i know you guys don't care about
all that but
i guess i'm trying to like encompass
like 15
10 or 15 years in a few sentences and
it's just not really possible
you know it was it was really fun um
i could probably just show some pictures
from and they might speak a thousand
words
all right i got an old photo album this
is actually before the move this is when
i was
younger than five so uh bear with me a
little bit and the green screen is
probably gonna
mess it up a little bit but we'll make
do i'll just i'll just throw up here i'm
just gonna show you a few i'm not gonna
show you that many
i might have to turn this screen thing
off for a second but this is
all right this is when we still lived on
the big
farm before the move and you can see or
just some kids running around and
farm messing with animals cats dogs
uh generally running around having a
good time
uh i think most of these are actually my
brother and sister because i was
really really young i was probably only
one or two at this time
yeah there we all are there's all of us
brother sister and oh
and me probably way on the end there why
am i doing holding it oh we're all
holding cats
we're each holding the cat yeah we you
know we loved our pets we were kids
so anyway we moved eventually
all right i found the perfect photo
album for this next section that i was
on
when i was growing we were growing up in
the
new place we moved to when i was five
and
what do we got okay so my dad took tons
of pictures
and always recorded stuff which is cool
now
because there's so much stuff
uh i say it's cool it is kind of cool
but there literally is so much stuff
there's piles and piles of his stuff to
go through
and it's a bit of a burden but i'm still
thankful for it because i've got things
like
i'm not going to show here but i've got
my parents marriage license in here
and uh here we go
here's here's some good ones um
geez i know they're getting
clouded but that's fine i don't want
them to be the perfect quality here
anyway
but just a bunch of uh us kids playing
and then i'm gonna find the ones at the
new place
all right here's here's a little sample
there's us camping
the whole family good times
there's uh us at the beach or something
doing something
and uh what else we got here is my dad
climbing
so it was it was a pretty good life
we had we had some chickens for a while
there's me holding the chicken
you get this lineup right yeah that's me
holding the chicken
yep that was probably six there
there's uh i'll show you just just a few
more there's
uh us with some friends holding melons
that we picked that year
it's watermelons i think up there i'm
trying to get it centered
most centered picture there but there's
just a ton there's albums and albums
full of these years and uh it's pretty
cool
it's pretty cool there's there's so many
of them that's kind of
you know that's uh just want to give you
a little sample
just just a little sample it's not
really what it's about
but it seems like a lot of people on the
internet for some reason
i don't know they they don't even
believe you're real until you have like
a full story it's weird
so i don't know and i'm sure a lot of
people are wondering at this point
but yeah we i grew up there and things
were interesting my
my mom was always really religious which
in some ways
was good but in some ways was also uh
maybe not so good so you know i really
want to talk about this more from an
engineering
perspective but i think this is
important
there's the church we ended up going
to was a pentecostal church and it was
a little different i i don't want to
give the whole full
story of that it's not really anything
that different from
you know the best thing i can do is
probably point you to a video that
someone else did
uh you probably know him if you watch my
channel because i think we get
piled together a tiny bit except his is
much bigger uh joshua fluke look up his
video about
his parent i don't know it's something
about
his church was in utah mine was on the
other side of the states but
same thing i believe he was in a
pentecostal church as well growing up
and he speaks about it quite openly what
it was like the whole speaking in
tongues and all that and a bit of the
over-the-topness you know um
girls have to wear skirts and you know
all that stuff your very strict rules
guys can't have long hair
there there was all these rules and
yeah i would say if you want to know
more about that just watch joshua
fluke's video honestly
about it's something like my parents
raised me in a cult or something like i
don't know i remember what he called it
but
i watched the video a while back and
it's it's basically the same thing
uh the stuff he says about how they the
pastors do stuff and how they try to
loop you in and get you to speak in
tongues it was basically like
that i went to a few church camps which
were um
well i guess when i'm being honest they
were a bit traumatizing
but i did learn a few important things
nothing really that critical other than
you know i i don't talk a whole lot
about religion because
i'm not a religious person and i think
you know i gave it a try i gave it an
honest shot so i'll talk about that a
little bit i guess
because i think during this phase where
i gave it an honest shot
is kind of when i had the clearest mind
like there are reasons for that it
didn't have anything to do with the
religion it's just that
when i decided to become a christian i
decided to like
i was still young i was in my teenage
years i think it was like 13 or
something i just decided that i was
going to live a clean
life like you know i just
stopped doing all bad things and only
studied and i got really good grades in
school during this period and stuff like
that
but ultimately it wasn't for me it only
lasted a few years and
some things happened and i decided
religion wasn't for me and
quite frankly it just didn't add up to
me um
i didn't really make this choice now
that i think about it it just kind of
happened
where some things clicked
and i realized that this
this couldn't be correct basically i
like you know i was
critically analyzing things all the time
putting things together
i started playing a lot of a lot of
strategy games when i was young
i think from about the age of
seven yeah ages seven on i i played a
ton of strategy games
on the console used to like games like
the original xcom
and uh castlevania and stuff like that i
would just play them all the time
super mario brothers and stuff like that
yeah i played xcom on playstation but
i didn't get a computer totals like 13 i
think or 14.
so there was this interesting period
where uh
trying to think how to word this but
basically i got
really really interested in video games
and electronics
and i guess this started even younger
because my brother and i would just
we shared a room and he was a couple
years older than me
but we basically anytime we got
electronics like a new
rc car or some other cool electronic
we'd use it for a while then as soon as
we got bored of it we just
take a screwdriver and take them apart
so we were always taking apart our toys
and occasionally just like experimenting
putting stuff together
and and building so that
that really i think excelled my
uh just in general my troubleshooting
the engineering ability
just getting to play around with little
motors and batteries and
legos and just actual rc cars and taking
them apart
before i knew what the heck i was doing
we were just up there crunching away
messing around with all these
electronics all day my brother and i
would sit in our room all day and just
take things apart and
toy around with electronics basically no
computers though we didn't have a
computer
my parents did not like computers nor
did they really understand even what
they were
i know that sounds weird but you know
you hear about a lot of people saying oh
i was
messing with whatever was out in that
80s early 90s but my parents were
completely
oblivious to what computers were they
they just didn't see the need for them
they didn't understand really
well my dad probably did because he went
to you know he went to school
and finished a degree and he worked at
um well i won't say exactly where
but he worked for the state for a while
and of course he had to like
make reports for his bosses and type
those up on the greener so he was fully
aware of what a computer was but he
didn't like it he would always be
complaining about computers
and saying that they were like causing
excessive radiation to him and stuff
like that
which we'll come back to um the things
about my dad that
about that sort of stuff just a bit of
her
you know signs of paranoia early on
about things like
just didn't trust technology and stuff
like that he was kind of old school
and uh yeah i just didn't like messing
with
technology really other than motors and
engines and stuff like that but not
computers and chips and
and things like that
all right so where do we go from here i
guess i guess i just jumped to my
my high school years because well
i don't know i feel like i'm leaving out
something important but
okay i guess one of the big things that
i feel like
saved my childhood in a way other than
video games and computers and and having
a decent
family unit was this game called magic
the gathering it's just a little card
game and i still play it
some to this day but i started playing
like the age of 11 and i was just
completely enthralled by just seeing
these
spell casters and and just the whole
idea
and the strategy behind it like playing
the game just the the amount of strategy
it took to
to actually win a game um especially
against
and just like putting decks together and
figuring out what works and what doesn't
and managing resources
and it was the game just kind of blew me
away and
thinking back on it now you know i had
no idea these cards would be worth
anything but like all those cards i had
back when i was a kid
most of them are you know they were
a ton of them are worth a ton of money
now i didn't keep them all
i started a new collection but that was
one of the games i played in my early
childhood that i feel like
had a huge influence i also had a huge
influence on the friends
that i chose and i think that's actually
quite important
because i i almost got mixed up with the
wrong crowd
multiple times and usually the reason
the thing that would pull me back
was often just video games or magic
i i was always looking for someone else
that was on my level
that could actually compete with what i
was doing at the time
because i was like over analyzing things
strategizing
you know in general i could usually beat
all my friends and
and all this stuff my brother and i
really took a liking to
a lot of fighting games mortal kombat
tekken
and some other ones mostly mortal kombat
tech and we played this like crazy we
played some other ones too but
we always came back to those and so my
brother and i
we would just play these all day and
then we'd have a friend over and
uh that was like it was subconscious at
the time
but that's just what we like because
we're always like
all right let's let our new friend i
don't know we'll just say jeff i didn't
have a friend named
jeff growing up but i'm just going to
use that name
all right jeff it's your turn hand him
the controller let them figure some
stuff
out and we would like be able to tell
pretty quickly how smart
our friend was based on how fast they
could pick up a game
and their ability to to learn and and
compete with us basically in these games
because we'd usually be like
we'd play there would be a bunch of us
and only two controllers so we'd play
this
way where it's like loser gives control
away so the winner would just keep
playing and stomping people
and everyone else would just be passing
off the controller as they lost trying
to beat the guy who's holding the crown
and we just do that for hours
and eventually someone would get bored
or something or sometimes it would go
back and forth
but like 90 percent of the time i would
be holding the crown
and people would be trying to beat me
occasionally i'd lose sure but
and that's not to brag it was a really
small sample size in a small town
so it's not like i was competing with
the biggest of the biggest it was just
random people from my school that you
know we had
become friends so
but i did notice that i kind of had more
of an aptitude for
all this just like uh
strategy type stuff of like figuring out
which ability to use
being fast of hitting the counter button
remember in the combos i would practice
diligently to learn all the combos so i
could pull them off when we're actually
playing
and in general i would just stomp people
all the time and it was a lot of fun
i did meet a few people that were on par
or better than me but most
for the most part majority time i was
always
quite a bit better at video games than
most people
and uh you know i never really took that
anywhere i never tried to be competitive
or anything like that
it's possible that i could have and i'll
say a little more about that because
it's kind of related
um yeah skipping forward a little bit
but i used to play
the first age of empires i played it a
ton when i was a kid i think i started
playing when i was like 15 or so
maybe 14. i kind of lost track but that
game
absolutely enthralled me and i played it
for years and i played online and i
started to play competitively
and some really interesting things
happen and i started to learn
a lot about
kind of like internet personas we'll say
because uh on in that game you would get
a reputation
it was a pretty small subset of people
that would actually play that game we
played on this place called the msn
gaming zone
anyone remember the msn gaming zone i
don't think it doesn't exist anymore
it's gone but that's where you found
lobbies and queued up for the game and
stuff
and so i was always on there and there
was you know
all the other people who played and
eventually would get to know each other
and i actually made some pretty good
friends
i remember it was weird because i was i
was really young i was like what
age was i maybe i was 13. i think i was
13 when i started playing age of empires
and
we've got our first computer or actually
my brother got a computer because he was
a little older
and he made a deal with some friend and
bought a computer with whatever money he
had saved
and i just i loved that thing that's
that was my first
computer it was my brother's and anytime
he wasn't on it i was like
oh yeah and age of empires was honest so
that's how i got introduced to that game
okay so to the msn gaming zone in that
yeah i kind of
i made some silly name some goblin name
from magic the gathering it was like mog
or something
and it was like no matter how good i was
at that game how many people i could be
all these experts that i could
compete with or sometimes be it didn't
matter
if my name was not a good name
i would not be recognized as
their uh you know on par with them
and it was really it kind of took me
back i and i thought i was just like i'm
just going to keep working at it
eventually people are going to recognize
me
and uh accept that this mog guy is
actually a good player
but it never happened it never happened
it was
crazy to me because basically what i
ended up doing was making alt names and
occasionally some of these alts would
like blow
up it was insane i would play with mog
all the time that wasn't the full name
it was mog something up
but i'd play with this mog name all the
time
and i would just get kicked out of
lobbies all the time no matter how many
people i played with no matter how many
times i would
show off my skills and be like look i
can stomp all of you guys
they would still be like we don't know
you're getting kicked it's like i play
all the time and they still wouldn't
recognize
me they still wouldn't know me but i
made an alt
i made a bunch of alts i guess but it
was interesting
to see some of the names i made i'd just
play one game
and people would be like head over heels
and in love with this
the other name or they would just be
like oh invite this guy get this guy on
my team he's super good
then i switched back to my other name
didn't matter how good i performed i'd
get kicked out
so there there was a lot to an image
into a name
a lot it almost you're it's it's
i'm still trying to wrap my head around
why this happened other than something
about recognition
and something about people liking a good
name
but yeah i so i had a few alts that if i
wanted to join expert games i would
literally have to log off my main
account
and log in to my alt account to get in
them because every people would
recognize me immediately on these alts
even if i'd only played a few games
like word would spread like i had this
name called like
uh paraphrasing i think it was like
nightmare land taker or something
they're like the name
land taker like really stuck to people
for age of empires
and that name just blew up they i would
always get invited people were like he's
on my team give me give me the land
taker guy he's a
beast and it was the same person you
know i would do the same stomping with
mog but people would just kick me out of
games on that one and be like nope
so i don't know there's some lesson
there but
that that kind of opened my eyes to you
got to have a good name you got to have
a good image which i'm still battling
with today
because i i don't care about that stuff
very much i'm all about the technical
ability
i don't care what you look like i don't
i don't care what your name is
it's all about what are you actually
like
and that just didn't work online and i
kind of learned that at that time
all right well there's so much more i
can say about this but
i'll just say a few more things
so at this time the idea of being a
programmer or
software developer was not even on my
radar i had
i didn't really know what that was i
would probably guess
that they made you know these software
for the computer but i didn't really
know like no one told me i didn't have a
mentor
i didn't i didn't know anyone else not
like a single other person
that talked about computers or games it
was like
it was just me figuring out stuff
jumping on these games talking to people
a little bit and starting to figure out
a few things here and there so
i often hear about people saying oh i
learned on basic or this or that when i
was really young
or had someone show me this or you know
i didn't have any of that
so i was just like i figured this all
out on my own basically
never had a mentor never had anyone say
oh this is that i was just like
poking around figuring stuff out on this
computer my brother didn't know like no
one knew how to use it
parents were basically afraid of
computers they were kind of scared of
the idea of me
even being on the computer and
you know none of my other family did i
didn't really know anyone at school that
had a computer
eventually later i met some people that
did but
at this time no idea but this
is this was my big intro was that age of
empires because things started happening
like
basically the the game was terrible at
launch like i had a population limit of
50
and you had to add some kind of tag on
the executable to set the population
limit different
and you had to edit the the registry
value somewhere
so i followed guides and and did that
stuff because you had to
basically or the game was unplayable pop
50 was terrible
you'd be like oh i just started and i'm
at max pop i can't even do anything
so everyone increased the pop it was
just the thing to do otherwise
the game was just completely terrible a
bit of an oversight on the developers
part i think but
whatever i didn't know any better at the
time i was just following guides
but yeah to play online you just you had
to set the population limit to at least
200
50
see in a match in that game you usually
have like 60 to 70 villagers
so with a population of 50
you you can't do anything like the games
took forever because nobody could ever
overtake the other one because
everyone's rocking like 20 villagers and
25 army and it's just the slowest pace
thing ever and towers were
busted because you could just tower up
and someone's tiny armor
army could never get past the towers
because
towers didn't take a population limit so
you had to have a big pop to
bust through towers basically is what it
came down to
in that game but i started to run into
hackers
people would be like well the cheats
were off on the gaming zone but of
course people would hack it and spawn
cars that would blow stuff up and laser
man and stuff it was really frustrating
as
like a really good player to encounter
that because
well what ended up happening a lot of
time
times and and what actually i think kind
of started getting me interested
in trying to figure out more stuff about
programming is
well okay so i play on this name that
nobody would ever give credit to or
recognize you know the mod name
and basically any time i would beat
somebody i would just be
a being i would be accused of being a
cheater and i was like i don't even know
how to do that i have no idea what you
mean
and then they bust out these cars
and and stuff and basically they turn on
their cheats because they thought i was
cheating and they just blow me up
and i was like what are you what are you
what are you doing
so i'm not allowed to win
i'm cheating if i win i don't even know
how to cheat have no freaking clue
and it just like it really really like
made me angry as a kid
that anytime i would win someone would
just turn on their
cheats and blow me up so i started to
try to figure it out i was like all
right if people are just going to bust
out their cheats on me i'd like to at
least be able to do it back
because i don't know i you know i played
with
i played a lot of games at this time and
played with game genies and one thing i
realized is that i didn't really like
cheats
i mean this occasionally find a cheat
that makes a game better
but 99 of the time as soon as you turn
cheats on a game
that's the last time you play it because
the game gets incredibly boring
and so typically i was just like no
let's play legit i want to play legit
pop limit 200 let's go
no cheats of course no cheats but people
would always just bust on their cheats
however they did it i still
actually don't know i'm sure i could
figure it out today if i wanted to but
at the time
being a complete completely new to to
all this stuff
i had no idea but i tried to figure it
out i was like you know searching on
yahoo
and being like all right how do you do
this stuff that people are doing to me
all the time every time i win and i
never figured it out
i never got my cheats enabled and i
still was like
just that name mog was just always
railed into the ground as a cheater
although no one ever saw me cheat
because i didn't even know how to i was
just
really fast i just got really good at
getting the problem at 200 and sending
my army at people that's basically all
you do
you get your problem into 200 with a
giant army as fast as possible
if you do it faster than your enemy you
can generally just send it at them
and they can't stop you and you win and
so i would do that
and if i would beat the other person
they'd be like you're cheater you're
cheating there's no one that can build
that fast you're hacking and then they
turn on their stuff and kill me and i'd
just be like
this game's stupid i'm mad now this
game's cool
but all these people that are playing it
are such idiots you know i was i was
just so
frustrated by that cheating so
eventually i did stop playing
or stop it was really hard to find the
people that did cheat because they would
always change their name and stuff
so you couldn't just be like oh he's a
cheater those people would
like you know they cheat on some name
and switch to another or something like
that
so you couldn't just tell
or there wasn't a list of people that
were banned there was no banning there
was no moderation
there was nothing like that but it was
really annoying
and so i don't know if there's a life
lesson there but it's like
if you're like the underdog and you
somehow make it
or you're an unknown and somehow make it
like people assume you cheated
and that you're uh you have no
credibility because you're unknown
and like merit and ability
just didn't matter if people just had
their own assumption about you and that
still sticks with me to this day
i don't really know how to handle it i
just kind of ignore people that
make those sort of assumptions but i
guess the lesson here is judge on merit
stop judging on your
i don't know preconceived notion of
anyone that's better than you is
cheating
that's a weird thing anyway it wasn't
all bad
i'm kind of telling the the bad part of
the name but under that name mog i did
make a few
really good friends that actually did
kind of see me for who i was and
that so i stuck with it i joined a clan
i got
to know some good friends it was often
like
really really cool to be underestimated
because i could jump in a game and
people would have no idea what i was
about to do because
even after years of playing that the
same name
people still didn't recognize that i was
good so i would just always surprise
them and i think that's why i got called
cheater but uh i could switch to the
other name and stomp people and no one
would ever call me a cheater
i don't know i don't know i still won't
get it to this day it doesn't it still
doesn't quite make sense to me something
about the
complex mind of other people and not
liking to be
beat by an unknown or something even
though i still don't understand how it
was unknown
it still blows my mind to this day how
do you stomp
people for two years straight and still
not get recognized
it's like doing a youtube channel for
five years and still not reaching a
thousand subs
i'm not bitter about my gaming channel
at all better
all right moving on from age of empires
i know i just talked about it a long
time but it was like a really really
interesting time in my life
and it went on for about four years i
think it stopped
when uh diablo 2 came out and diablo 2
took over
oh i have a great picture i could dig it
up it's somewhere in my
somewhere in my place here of me playing
diablo 2
and my friend like sitting there like
trying to pull me away like let's go do
something but i didn't want to do
anything but play diablo 2.
because i was really addicted to that
game was really fun level 95 barbarian
that's really hard to get to i played a
ton
there's more stories behind that i'll
tell a few i guess because
okay so you know i said like for a while
i tried being a christian
and during this time i was playing age
of empires a ton so i mostly was just
at home being a legit honest person just
getting
just studying the craft of this game and
getting really good at it
ignoring the toxicity and you know
when i when i dive into something i tend
to like stick with it no matter what i
don't like to i don't like to
cheat or anything like that probably the
reason why most of my
projects grow so slow is i don't like
advertising
and i i view advertising as cheating
um if something's ever advertised to me
i
try not to ever buy it i try to ignore
advertisements basically
and i think these years had something to
do with that because it's like all these
people that
sorry to go back to age of empires again
but one more one more time because i
think
i think this is important i think this
is something that's subconsciously in me
now
and there's nothing in that's gonna
change it like
okay so a lot of times some of these
people that would bust
that would call me a cheater in this
game because i was beating them and then
bust out
their cheats were really well known
in the in the age of empires community
and like highly thought of as good
players that were
legit and high quality
and wouldn't do any wrong
they were often the ones that were the
actual cheaters
like all these reputable people were
the ones that shouldn't have been they
were the they were the ones that should
have been banned you know
but for some reason it was happening to
me because they had
the image and i didn't you know it was
or something it was
well it wasn't like a community decision
it was just you know it was just a
single game where
someone decided that and was like all
right busting out my cheats and there
was no
forums to post and say this guy's
cheated his reputations ruined they
could just deny it
i i honestly didn't even know how to
take screenshots at the time like kindly
did but i didn't know like how to upload
them properly or do stuff like that
i eventually started experimenting with
little sites but
that came a little later at the time
when i first saw these cheats coming at
me where i was like
what wait you called me a cheater
but you're the one cheating it just
happened over and over
the first few times i didn't even know
what to do i was just kind of blown away
by the
com the complexity of that sorry to keep
coming back to this but i think that's
why
partly i hate advertising because
companies with bigger reputations are
usually the ones advertising
well not anymore but like you see
colgate commercials and you know all the
big products and stuff like that
and i i think i just view advertising as
like
cheating or immoral and
i really wish there was another way to
get monetized on
youtube other than ads because i really
don't like ads
but i don't really there's not really
another option i know they're sponsors
and stuff but i've had like
one opportunity for sponsors i've i've
couldn't i could have made like
100 bucks in sponsors so far with
youtube
that that's such a small amount that it
doesn't matter you know so
i don't really have an option sorry if
you guys hate ads i don't mind if you
use the ad block or whatever
but i just kind of leave them default
and whatever so i have i've
and i know some people don't realize
this so i'll just say it
i have no control over what ads appear
on my channel sometimes people leave a
comment like
oh it goes the ads on this video go to
show a lot about things and i'm like i
don't know what that means i don't know
what ad you saw it's going to be
different a week
comments useless because no one's going
to see the same ad you just saw
that you're commenting on you can't
comment on the ads it's going to change
you can only comment on the content of
the video
so some people still don't realize that
where was i
i don't know diablo diablo so
yeah i was about 17 started playing
diablo and i just
i gave up on the whole christianity
thing at that point well i didn't give
up
like i said earlier i didn't really it
wasn't a conscious decision it just sort
of happened
things clicked i realized that it didn't
add up
it didn't make sense to me i didn't
really have a choice i couldn't just say
i'm a christian i believe in god anymore
because logically that didn't make sense
i would basically be
lying if i said that which i i try to be
moral i'm not perfect sure i felt i i
might you know i'm not going to pretend
that
i've never lied or something like that
but in general i don't like to lie
if i say something i will i want it to
be true
in general so
i felt like once i once all the stuff
clicked i didn't really have a choice
i couldn't just say oh yeah i believe in
god oh yeah i'm a christian
because it that's
no matter how much i wanted to no matter
how much
you know it didn't matter it didn't make
sense i
wasn't in my control anymore i'm sorry
that it doesn't add up to
those of you who like want me to be
saved or whatever
i wish it had it up too but it just you
know i tried
for a solid four years of my life for it
to make sense and for a while it did
for a little little bit of time but as i
matured and got better at
critically thinking and stuff it stopped
making sense
and it just it wasn't a conscious
decision i made
it was just like sometimes i feel bad
about that because my mom's
extremely religious and would like me to
be too
but i i i don't
it's not in my control i i would just
have to fake it which would just be a
big lie
and would feel even worse so usually i
just kind of knock along
when she's praying or whatever
i don't know or i think of it
differently
like for me uh the closest thing to
i don't know it depends on your
definition of god i guess i'll talk
about this briefly
but i don't know there's the sun of
course
the sun it might be really close to a
god for us
it does give us life it fits a lot of
the definition of god and
a lot of uh old religious theory or i'm
not sure if i'm saying this right but
uh the origin of the idea of god is
thought to have come from the sun
so i'm sure someone could find something
to support that but
uh i think the movie zeitgeist might say
it there's a there's a bunch of
documentaries about stuff like that you
can look it up but
it makes more sense than you know
the uh the other versions at least to me
but also each individual we're kind of
gods of ourself in a way
so there's something there where you
know we
we have the power over ultimately what
we
uh want to do with our lives so in a way
we're kind of
gods of ourselves i don't know something
like that
it adds up a little better than the
other pentecostal versions to me
but i don't really dwell on that too
much anymore it's not that big of a deal
so how much of my childhood do i skip
here
i don't know i've already skipped a ton
i'm sure i'm leaving out a lot of little
details
but overall i'd say i had a decent
childhood
but some things happened some things
really started to like
collapse with our family when i was
about 16 17.
and it was uh it was really
heartbreaking it kind of shattered my
world
and it took me a long time to recover
and i think
well i'm not real sure how to make sense
of it
really even to this day of the total
effect it had on me
and i don't i don't even think other
people like my other good friends and
stuff even really knew
what was going on exactly because i
didn't really talk about it but
basically my uh
my dad grew up
in a very abusive household i know i
showed you like pictures of him
he basically from what i understand
obviously i wasn't born yet so i've only
heard stories
he basically grew up
protecting his sisters from his dad
and so basically he took all the abuse
for the most part i don't know the full
extent of it
other than it was really bad you might
think
you might have an idea of what bad is
it's worse
you might have an idea of what worse is
it's it's worse than that
you might have an idea of what worse
than that is it's worse than that
it's still worse whatever idea of how
bad you think it is it's still worse
it's pretty bad
so my dad was pretty terribly abused
i remember him telling me a story
a few years before he passed away
about how he almost died when he was
five
basically from neglect and abuse
from from his dad
so
i don't know i i think he did all right
considering the
cards he was dealt because he was a
pretty good dad overall
but there were always signs of him being
different or
weird or a little a little twisted or
i'm trying to think the right word for
it but like i said he did
manage to go to school and finish the
degree and get a good job and
raise a family and be a decent guy but
he always kind of had this
twisted side to him like a weird sense
of humor
and maybe maybe i have a little bit of
that now too
that you know subconsciously or
something but i'm quite a bit different
from my dad
i would almost say we're nothing alike
but
in some ways we might have the same like
little twitches or whatever you know
just genetic stuff
but basically um
in his midlife he developed
schizophrenia
and was in and out of mental
institutions and
my his you know my mom and him got
divorced and
that kind of like i don't know i was uh
15 i think when it started
it really uh it really affected me quite
strongly
but i can i guess it's better at 15 than
when i was really young so i'm really
thankful for those
years where he was normal and working
and
being a good dad but at some point that
that shifted and he just became
someone that wasn't very attached to
reality anymore
and i didn't know how to deal with that
i had never met anyone like that before
i had never studied mental illness of
any sort i i didn't really even
understand what was happening
i didn't i didn't know his childhood was
that bad at the time it wasn't till
much later in my life that i began
began asking his sisters and you know my
aunts and
other people about what it was like and
starting to get an understanding of what
it was like for him growing up all i
knew was that he was on a farm and i
thought it was fine
i had no idea that was that bad but i
don't want to talk about that a ton
just you know he was an engineer
he was pretty good at it he's pretty
good dairy farmer
but ultimately he was plagued by these
problems that probably were all seated
when he was really young based on the
stuff that happened to him but and i'm
always
i'm always trying to imagine
who he would have been if
he had a good childhood
because i i don't know he could he could
have been something great you know
he was really interested in the arts and
acting and all that stuff i don't want
to go on
about my dad forever but
we'll just say he was a clever chap and
he deserved better
it wasn't wasn't fair what happened to
him
and i don't think it was very fair that
no one really understood
why he got schizophrenia you know if
people were just like ah he's crazy he's
messed up don't mess with that guy he'll
lead you off a cliff he's insane you
know it was it was that sort of thing
but there was more to it
there was an underlying issue that
didn't get addressed
and that nobody talked about and he was
like you know
that was that was part of the family
secret there's more to it than that i'm
not telling you the whole thing but
i don't know it's just really messed up
it's just really messed up
i gotta i'm gonna step away for a second
okay all right so this video is supposed
to be about how i came to be a
programmer i'm realized i'm getting
totally sidetracked
but i just don't want to leave out any
important parts about
what led me to this because at this time
i'm
what 15 to 17 i'm talking about playing
lots of video games
playing all these video games and age of
empires and
getting uh and having hackers
beat me after calling me the cheater and
then being the cheater themselves
that really defined me a lot and
honestly i
i can barely even look at anyone popular
or well-known and think that they
got it in a legit way well it's not true
entirely but for a lot it's it's i feel
like it's
really easy for me to tell who's fake
these days
because of that it's like i can look at
some big youtubers
and and pretty quickly as
i don't like to assume but a lot of them
it's pretty obvious that
they didn't naturally grow you know
you can tell the ones who did you know
like markiplier
pretty naturally grew i don't know
i i have really no idea i shouldn't drop
names that's just like the first thing
that came to my head is someone that
seems like a legit
youtuber but like for me it's probably
going to be the slowest growing thing
ever because i'm
i'm never going to buy views i'm never
going to advertise i'm not even going to
tell my friends about this channel in
fact i don't unless it's relevant to
something we're discussing or whatever
you know
i i don't advertise this channel i don't
talk to people about it just discover
naturally
because i i like things to be i like
like things to be known for their merit
not for their advertising i
i strongly despise advertising like i
was like i said
and i think part of that was just
seeing the advertisement of oh this
guy's a great player you want to play
with him you learn a lot from him and
then to find out that
they're just some dirty cheater they
don't even play legit
like really really stung in something i
don't know it just it was an eye-opener
it was just like holy crap
so all these people that make it are
just like cheating their
way and then and then people still and
people still
give them credit even after they know
their cheater they don't like
say hey you can't do that just let them
do it let them stay on top
i don't know i guess it happens a lot in
a lot of different industries but that
kind of stuff
makes me lose a little bit of faith in
humanity but i think most people are
mostly good so it's not it's not that
bad
all right so yeah about age 17
i was dating this girl and
things were going okay but i sort of s
you know my i sort of like went
into this mode where i wasn't
i don't even know how to explain it i
feel like
i was just in a zone for years i started
to party a lot
i started i don't know what the heck i
started doing honestly
i basically just started to party more
and
i didn't really do anything that serious
you know drank a little bit alcohol
smoked a little
devil's lettuce but nothing more than
that never interested more than that and
then i
and then i cut it off at some point but
there was a period of time in my life
and it was kind of when my dad
started going crazy that i started just
like
turning to other things i guess and i
was very subconscious at the time i
didn't really even think about it just
kind of happened
but it didn't last super long i uh
in high school i was pretty well
recognized as
the guy that's good at math yeah i think
it's good grades and that sort of thing
because i had been like super clean and
straight for years
studying really hard and i don't know i
guess all this practice when video games
helped the logical ability too
or something i don't know i was school
was never super challenging for me but
so my guidance counselor was basically
like oh you're going to devry for
computer engineering and i was like okay
sounds good so i went
and i didn't like it at all so my time
at devry
was good but not because of the school
it was good because of the people i met
i met some really good friends there
that i'm still friends with to this day
and pretty much most of us quit that
school and went to other schools
i would not recommend devry right i
don't
i don't mean to basta fry i'm sure it's
good for a lot of people
but it was not good for me it was it was
pure misery for me i should have went to
a bigger school with more people because
the variety was like
you go into the building you take your
classes you'll leave there's no
there's no other people to hang out with
or talk with really other than about the
class or your homework for a bit but
there's
you know there's no dorms everyone lives
off campus that sort of thing
i should have been on i should have been
in a more traditional
school where there's more community
because devry was just like
we're going to teach you this stuff and
then then you leave you're outdoor go
work
there's no there's not much community
going on here so i didn't really like
that i was
really in a mode where i wanted to hang
out with people and
you know find my crew so to speak which
i did
and they were all incredibly nerdy
people and it was it was fun
it was a good experience overall but oh
i wouldn't
personally i wouldn't recommend to ride
to anybody it was just so expensive and
there was
just not much to take away from the
courses it really wasn't
at least not at the time maybe it's
changed but i basically just
after a couple years i just quit i was
just like i don't even know why i'm
doing this i don't want to do this at
all
but it was all right i got my first
taste of like what programming was there
and it was terrible i just i basically
decided there's no way i want to
be a programmer at that time because
they taught us in java and
their messages for like when
you know you didn't write your program
correctly
didn't really do anything they just
basically said error
no no hint of what line or what the
problem was just
failed to compile good luck and it would
i don't know everybody
just everybody would be sitting in that
lab for hours
raging like i don't know what the heck
is wrong with this do you see this
everybody be looking at it we'd all just
be trying to figure it out
and it was just pure misery but cody's
not really like that anymore
even the harder languages you at least
usually get pretty decent error messages
so but that didn't i didn't really
have an underlying goal i didn't realize
what i wanted to do at the time i was
just kind of like
following the advice so it's i think
that's the big reason i didn't stick
with it
so i started hanging out with a few
other friends we went to a lot of
concerts
and i decided i wanted to start playing
music so i picked up a guitar
well i broke up with my girlfriend and
started playing guitar that's basically
what happened and quit school
quiz school brought wrote my girlfriend
started playing guitar played guitar
non-stop
and one of the reasons was i was really
into music i was in a lot of rock music
i was
listening to stuff like tool and
i honestly think that like bands like
tool kind of saved me
i listened to all their albums a ton and
it's like
what you know just like dealing with my
dad's
craziness at the time like that music
just
brought me some kind of comfort and
kind of back to reality and helped me
connect with others
so i felt like music had kind of saved
my
saved my mind my mental state and i
decided i wanted to make music so i did
so throughout my 20s my whole 20s
basically
what i did the majority of the time is i
worked i worked a lot of random tech
jobs because i i kind of got pigeonholed
into that
friend helped me get a job at geek squad
and i started from there
started doing a bunch of other stuff
just a lot of little companies
doing a lot of tech stuff a lot of
computer repair a lot of just
helping people with computers i didn't
really enjoy it
i enjoyed the parts about like
mechanically messing with computers and
rebuilding and all that stuff that was
pretty fun
but i really did not like helping people
with computers like
to go through the misery of helping
someone click a button for like 10
minutes
it's probably the worst experience ever
i never want to do that again it's like
just click the button just click the
freaking button how else do i tell you
to just click
okay what do you want from me click ok i
don't know
you know it was uh helping people with
computers is
still a source of misery for me i i
don't like it
i uh i don't know really what to do
about that because i think it annoys
some people i'm like you know
when we have like family get-togethers
and stuff a lot of people come to me
with their computer problems
and quite frankly i don't care i don't
care what your computer problem is
unless you have something physically
broken and want me to like you know fix
that that's fine
but as far as you like learning how to
use your computer i don't care figure it
out however you want to figure it out
it's not click ok you know click the
button
type in the website google it you don't
need me for this you
don't need me for this all right well
anyway
but yeah i get it your hard drive went
bad you need new os i can do all that i
can take apart
throw a new hard drive in there whatever
i've done that a million times
but web browser
yeah go for it i don't i don't know use
it however you want to use it
so i i was more into hardware for a long
time well i was in the software like
personally but it just really annoyed me
to like try to teach people and there
wasn't like a single person
this was just in general like uh
i just in general didn't didn't like
uh helping people with computers
basically other than
you know if they come to me with that
needing to repair then that's cool
or if they just wanted you know
something something that was
straightforward something that wasn't
like impossible to show them
for some others all right well so i
played a lot of music and i started to
write songs
and i started to what did i do i don't
know i just played guitar all the time
listen to music all the time
tried to get into bands but as you can
imagine
starting to play guitar at the age of 20
and trying to get in the bands didn't
work
very well at first because i was really
bad at guitar compared to everyone else
like i would try out for band and i
would try to sing or
or play and it would i would just be
really bad compared to everybody else
because
you know they'd been in bands that was
their thing for a long time but i was
completely new
so i basically had a really hard time
getting into any bands at first
so i just started writing a lot of my
own stuff and i've still got piles and
piles of my own songs
that i've never released or shown to
anybody really
who knows some of them might be hits you
never know
but uh you know a lot of them were just
me toying around
i feel like some of them were good but
the world will probably never know i
don't think i'll ever release them or
show them to anybody
i'd have to redo them i'm sure they're
as of today they're probably really
not up to my standards i i probably
cringe a lot
and be like no i'm not showing that to
anybody but eventually i did get into a
few bands a friend and i formed one and
we wrote a bunch of songs and that was
pretty cool
uh didn't really get very far as far as
like
you know making a proper record we had a
few demos and
it was basically a lot of fun and a good
learning experience because we were kind
of at the same stage and kind of grew
together some
but eventually we hit a wall
this was a few years later and i'm
skipping a lot of stuff here
uh i guess i should talk about the
computer stuff that was influencing me
i was starting to get into sound
engineering and recording
and i was often like you know trying to
record these demos and figuring out
stuff and figuring out mics and trying
different recording software and stuff
like that
so and i was also playing a ton of world
of warcraft i i really got sucked into
the original world of warcraft it came
out
i was working some traveling computer
job world of warcraft came out
i thought hey this seems really cool
i'll give it a try so i played it
and then i was hooked every weekend
i would play it non-stop and then i'd go
travel for the week
come back for the weekend play it
non-stop get a few levels
so that went on for a while and
eventually i just quit my job and did
nothing but play world of warcraft and
play music
and and work locally rather than
traveling that way i could play more
and it was it was really fun met a lot
of cool people
still friends to this day we're still
friends on like instagram and stuff and
we still talk
some of us a lot of really cool people
that i met that's
like i almost can't express
how grateful i am not not for
not just for world of warcraft but for
like
how it brought me to other like-minded
people
i was able to find other people that
were kind of on the same wavelength as
me and you know we guilded up
beat the n-bosses i was like one of the
few people on my server that had all the
end game gear because
as you might imagine from the computer
stuff i've talked about i
tended to be pretty good at these things
so i froze the ranks pretty quickly and
guilds and stuff
and it was awesome just
to have that big community and people
laughing and you know to actually make
some
takeaway friends that last beyond the
game was really cool
and to kind of get to know them in their
life and their stories
i kind of lost my trainees up here uh
but yeah i guess i started messing with
mods in world of warcraft some
not a ton i started to like learn a
little bit about how to make them but i
was like yes that's a lot of work i'll
just use what other people made
and that's about as far as it went so i
didn't get a whole lot of programming
experience really from
portal craft world of warcraft other
than like what
could be done and just seeing that sort
of thing was pretty cool
but that came from what i understand is
like a modern marvel of
programming there's a lot going on or
for the you know it's a whole world of
tons of people on a server and it
manages to be pretty stable and the
bosses and instances
there's a lot behind that it's pretty
cool but on the side i was playing music
so it was funny like the first
microphone i had when everyone was like
i get a mic and a headset because i
didn't i didn't have one
at first i was like okay so i hooked up
my like amp microphone and put it up in
front of me
and had it through this whole effects
board so i can like press all these
guitar effects and stuff and do it with
my voice and i would like mess with
people
but it was also like really quiet so
people were like i can't hear you so i'd
always be like cranking it and then it'd
be like whoa man you're way too loud and
i was like i can't find the right level
but yeah i was basically rather than
just having a standard
you know headset like everybody else i
was like using my guitar recording
equipment
as my microphone and
those were good days that was those were
good times
um and someone was i remember someone
trying to help me
and being like okay well just you know
they thought they were pretty savvy and
could help me figure out my mic
and they're like all right dude what
kind of setup do you have is it like a
normal setup i'm like oh no
it's not normal at all ah good times
but yeah eventually i did get a proper
headset and stuff so
but that's that's just something that i
remember
now anyway i'll skip forward a few years
eventually i did get into a band
um i guess i'm leaving out a lot of
stuff there was
why i was at devry so this is going back
many years
uh man i skipped a lot of stuff you know
i said i broke up with my girlfriend and
left school and started playing guitar
there was a girlfriend before that
that we were kind kinda high school
sweethearts type of deal and uh after
high school
she got pregnant and we had a little
girl so i had a little girl
and um
her mom and i we broke up things went
really bad
really suddenly very quickly and uh
it's i don't know how much i want to
talk about that but
yeah i think i'll just leave that out
for the most part let's
i you know i don't want to like start
playing the blame game or something as
many years later that's pretty crazy but
basically um it turns out we weren't all
that compatible after all
and we were just completely different
roads you know
i you know what i do you hear what i've
been talking about that's that's what i
did
that didn't sit well with her in the
long run she
she didn't like me being a gamer and
that sort of thing
and there was more to it than that she
had her own issues i had my other own
issues and things like that but it
basically just didn't work out
but that was also one of the reasons i
left school when i started dating some
other girl and
then i broke up with her and left school
and kind of reset
but okay well there i cleared that up
hopefully enough
eventually i'll get to yeah still at
this time in my throughout my 20s i'm
still not a programmer
i did not program at all so
i just played games music a lot
eventually got into a band that wasn't
just a couple buddies you know it was
actually a real band we toured we wrote
songs we made albums
uh lasted for a while i guess i could
show a picture of that
it's actually all over the internet and
i think
um i don't know i don't know if i really
want to say it too much
but basically as soon as we kind of
started to break through and make it
the band broke up there was a lot of
stress we were in a lot of debt
uh none of our shows really made money
our
guitar player which wasn't me i was
playing bass actually at this time
because i had switched to bass uh at
some point i just
forget why i think it's because uh in
the
band i was or the buddy i was jamming
with a bunch and we were writing songs
he played guitar
and i played guitar and it was like we
were having this trouble where we like
taking up the same frequency so all of
us had to do something different
so i started playing bass and it was
pretty yeah i enjoyed it i really liked
bass
and that's that's how i got in this
other band as a bass player
so i was playing bass for this it was
basically a a punk rock band
and it was a lot of fun it was it was a
good time
met a lot of other big bands
um yeah i've met a lot of a lot of other
punk bands
you'd probably know some of them the
atari's
uh a reformed version of the misfits
with
jerry only and uh who else
uh michael graves we got to know him
kind of well
that one of the misfits singers second
one i think
and there are a bunch of others uh that
aren't as well known but a lot of cool
people met a lot of cool people
uh our guitarist and the singer were
kind of the
creators of the band and they kind of
fronted a lot of money making
merchandise and getting albums made
and uh so they were in pretty big debt
so anytime we did make
money they would basically take it all
and
so i was i i didn't make anything and
neither did our drummer we just
you know every show was a loss basically
like we'd spend our gas and time and all
that and there wasn't anything for it
other than we'd gain a little reputation
maybe
so it was really a really slow grind and
it was really wearing on everybody
and our guitarist at some point it was
just like man i'm cutting my losses i
have to quit
i'm already so in debt uh from this and
and we're not exactly making it back and
there was that was basically going on
and he had some other stuff going on too
but
basically he left and we i think the
other members wanted to replace
him but i was like look if if he's going
i'm going so i quit too
because well i don't know if i want to
get too
into the reason but basically i kind of
saw him as the
figurehead i didn't see it as the same
band once he left
so i just was like yeah this isn't gonna
work anymore
and i just left too
there's more to it than that it was uh
it was interesting then i joined another
band after that a hard rock band
and we played some and it was really
awesome actually really good experience
with this other hard rock band
and i think we were kind of starting to
get somewhere but i had
another kid at this time i was kind of
got seriously involved with
another girl in my late 20s and
we were considering marriage we had a
kid a little boy
you might have seen in some of my videos
he's a great kid
and he's with me the majority of the
time because his mom is
usually at work she's she's great too
but we ended up splitting up we didn't
stay together but we're still friends
and stuff so it's all good
but we're just uh you know oh yeah
it's probably my fault and that's fine i
i didn't think it i wasn't very happy
basically with things i don't know
things happen you just got to make the
best of it basically
and it's it's all fine now but uh
yeah so that happened and i was
basically like all right well
that's why that's why i quit the the
hard rock band later and that was it
that was that was basically the end of
my career i kind of at that point you
know i had toured a bunch had made
albums i had
been successful for me you know
not like a giant commercial success but
i was really happy to be able to create
songs go meet all these people be on
stage
you know get mod they'll actually be on
stage playing and see a mosh pit get
going from your music it's something
really special
not like a total mosh pit but we weren't
that heavy or that big
but you know there were some times that
were like really special nights
where really awesome things happened and
i'll never forget those
so i kind of had my fill of it i guess
at that point and
the i was i was content i guess with
where
the music went i was but i was done i
had checked out i was like i'm not
joining any more bands
i'm selling most of my gear and that
sort of stuff
so i still play a little bit and every
once in a while i'll go and uh
fire up the old amp and jam out for a
bit but
it doesn't happen a whole lot anymore
and i don't foresee myself joining any
more bands or writing many more songs
i think that era is over and it was
right about this time
i was working for a university doing
tech support
and i had been doing it for a few years
and met a lot of cool people but i was
starting to get to know some of the
people that worked on like the
engineering team and stuff like that
and start and also like it was pretty
clear that i had an aptitude for this
sort of thing
like a long time ago and i just hadn't
done it so
it basically clicked one day that i just
want to make games i just want to make
video games i have all these stories in
my head i also played a ton of dungeons
and dragons and was always the dm
and made a bunch of stories and loved it
and i was always thinking man that was
so epic and that was so or
that was so cool or how cool would it be
to go through this in a video game and
get to
you know there was all this stuff like
in my head and i was like how do i
actually do that so i started
researching and basically found out that
um you need to learn software
development
and i liked it i was also messing with a
lot of cryptocurrency at the time
like when bitcoin first came out uh
i remember seeing it at uh ten bucks
a coin buddy and i were uh you know in
the shop
repairing computers all the time the way
we would stress test them was we'd go on
this website and have it mine bitcoin
for our accounts
and it was nothing at a time nobody
cared nobody it wasn't on anybody's
radar as a thing 10 bucks a coin
10 bucks a coin so we got to the point
where like
we had each mined up about a coin we're
like hey we can buy a coffee or two or
we could buy a burrito with this you
know
that that was that was what you could do
with
um a portion of a bitcoin at the time
and uh we basically just didn't care
and i i don't know where that bitcoin
went honestly i had it i think i had
point seven
which i was like hey it's like seven
bucks you know
and uh i don't know i just kind of
forgot about it it
was like it was going to be really hard
to turn that
into actual cash and i was like it's not
worth time seven bucks you know
but now looking back at it's like crap
that was .7 of a bitcoin i should have
kept that
so a lot of a lot of stuff like that
happened but it's fine i still got in
early i still had
a lot of fun with the crypto and still
do to this day so
that's a big portion of uh how
i can easily maintain things is
basically i
i didn't like cash out big i actually
cashed out really stupidly
um yeah i definitely sold at bad times
with the crypto so i didn't make a whole
lot but
it's it's enough that it helped me
go to school and start trying to pay off
some bills and stuff and
yeah things are fine now i think things
are fine
i wouldn't say i'm rich or anything like
that but
i also wouldn't say i'm broke you know
eventually i'd go broke unless
i keep these investments sorted out and
make sure they don't go to nothing but
um yeah that that sort of thing also
kind of made me get interested
in programming because when we were
doing that
we were also trying to figure out how to
make our own coin and basically
looking at c and c plus plus and be like
i don't know how does this work
so so yeah eventually what happened is i
got really sick of my desk job answering
phones and tech support at this
university and said look i'm going
i'm taking courses i'm going to go for a
degree in computer science and i'm going
to finish it no matter what
so i did and
about four years later i had a computer
science degree and
i loved programming programmed all the
time
i made this channel at about my second
or third year
because well basically because i
couldn't find any of the content that
was actually helpful like i was trying
to figure out
like one of the early videos i did about
uh see plot
kind of have to look one of the early
videos i did
just about how to get ming gw working on
sea lion it was like not intuitive at
all it took me forever to figure out so
i was like i'll make a video about it
and then i tried to make the video
and things still didn't go well even
though i had done it previously
and tried to just repeat the process and
it still didn't work well and you can
see in that video
in my sea lion cmake or
yeah i don't know it's one of my first
videos
you can see in that video the struggle
and that was real i was very new
programmer
then i still i still consider my that's
why i consider myself new still is like
i haven't been programming since i was a
kid
i've been uh you know pretty
technically adept since i was a kid and
practicing
logic and stuff like that as a kid in
general engineering
but i didn't actually pick up
programming until i was
30 and went back to school you know
i touched a little bit early on you know
and jabba
devry looking at the world of warcraft
mods and
age of empire stuff but
i never actually dug in and learned how
to do it
until i was 30. that was when i you know
first actually compiled a program and
was interested and i actually owe it to
one of the first teachers i had
she was great she was awesome nice i can
still hear her voice anytime my program
isn't working
walk through the code walk through the
code
walk you know so it's like a mantra that
she repeated
to the first students just to just walk
through the code step by step
so i'm always hearing that in my head
when things aren't working it's like all
right start
top go slow check everything make sure
it's all lined up
yeah i guess i guess that's it i guess
that's all i'm going to say
how long have we been recording an hour
and 20 minutes i don't think i'm going
to cut this
it it's probably just better in its full
form
thanks for watching thanks for being
part of this and uh yeah
just figured i'd kind of let you know
where i came from and
that sort of thing
so yeah
appreciate uh the support people who
leave comments really appreciate the
patrons i know there's not a ton of you
guys but a few of you
that are there it means a lot to me it
really does
that you guys are you know want to see
me keep making content and
i plan on doing that but i do need to
buckle down and finish what i've been
working on i'm trying to get this game
engine going and i've been like
totally stuck on animations and shaders
for a long time and it's kind of
it's kind of it's kind of wearing on me
so i don't know where i'm going with
that i really i really want to make some
tutorials on this stuff once i figure it
out because
to be perfectly honest and one of the
reasons i can't quite figure it out is
i haven't found any good documentation
every single animation tutorial is the
same
there there is no variety there there's
only one animation tutorial out there
and all the others are just a repeat of
that so
i don't want to do that people have been
waiting for me to make this animation
tutorial how to do animations with c
plus plus and the assimp library and i
still plan on making it
but i want to figure it out for myself i
want to understand it for myself and i
want to give you my version of it i'm
not just going to
copy and paste from learn opengl or open
opengl
dev or thin matrix or all those guys
they did an okay job but it's all just
the same thing and to be to be honest
i've went through them all multiple
times and it still doesn't
i still don't get it so there's
something about those that
doesn't click easily and i always see a
lot of comments like i can't get this to
work can't get that to work
so yeah i get it
no nobody knows how to do these
animations nobody well not nobody i'm
sure
somebody does but it's like it's like a
trade secret
because however those tutorials are
showing is definitely not the best way
that i have assessed and uh
yeah i'll get it eventually and i will
i'll make a tutorial for you guys about
how i figured it out
anyways thanks again i'm gonna i'm gonna
roll
you guys in a weird way are like my
new family uh it's really weird to say
but you know
i'm not used to getting this many
comments about my stuff and things like
that so
it does it does mean a lot thanks again
i'll see in the next video peace out
you